we now would like to apply our
energy-momentum rule and momentum to
analyze a one-dimensional elastic
collision with no external forces let's
remind ourselves we'll call it the
energy momentum equation said that the
relative initial was equal to the
relative final so we have V 1 X initial
minus V 2 X initial that's the initial
relative the X component of initial
relative velocity is equal to the final
X component of the relative velocity and
that was our energy momentum law now the
momentum condition that its constant was
our equation V 1 X mishel plus m2v2 X
initial equals M 1 V 1 X final plus M 2
V 2 X final now let's see how this
linear system is much much easier to
solve let's look at it the same problem
that we solved before where M 2 was
equal to 2 m 1 and also we were in the
laboratory frame so V 2 X initial is 0
and that tells us that the initial
velocity relative velocity is simply the
velocity of object 1 so let's just write
our two equations down again and see how
much simpler our system is V 1 X initial
is minus V 1 X final plus V 2 X final so
we have minus plus and our momentum
condition remember V 2 X initial is 0
the M 1 and 1 M 2 will be 2 m 1 so we
can cancel our M ones and we get V 1 X
initial equals V 1 X final and M 2 is
twice M 1 so there's a factor plus 2 B 2
X final now I want to solve for our
target variable I look at these two
equations it's I can see almost
immediately that if I add
these two equations v1x initial will
cancel and I get very simply by adding
we get to be 1x initial and this is 3b
2x final or V 2x final is two-thirds V 1
X initial and let's just call this
equation 1 and 2 so we added and now to
find the 1x final we let's see what
we'll do there so we can do this
a variety of different ways I think the
simplest thing here to do we could
eliminate the 2x final by multiplying
through by minus 2 or we can simply
substitute in B 2x final right here and
we get so let's do that let's substitute
that in right there and we get the 1 X
initial equals V 1 X final plus 2 times
2/3 V 1 X initial when we bring that
over to the other side 1 minus 4/3 is
minus 1/3 B 1 X initial equals V 1 X
final and at the cost of introducing a
new concept we found the algebra much
much simpler to solve in this problem
and we can just double check our result
that the initial velocity relative
velocity was simply the X 1 and the
final relative velocity the relative
final is minus V 1 X final
- lets see the v-final relative velocity
is V 1x final B 2x final I hat and when
we put that in we have minus one-third
the 1x initial minus two-thirds v1 X
initial I hat and we have minus v1 X
initial I hat which is minus the
relative initial and so we see that the
relative velocity simply changed
direction
this approach is much much easier and
keep in mind that the energy momentum
and the momentum laws are thus just
rewriting our two fundamental constants
of motion kinetic energy and momentum